drop your trousers and get ready to sign
the book of the beast because it's
episode two of the chilling Adventures
of Sabrina and this one has abs picking
up where we left off in Episode one
Satan Pope tells Sabrina about the book
of the Beast the most ancient tome in
existence the Beast referring to the
monster that appears during the
apocalypse in the book of Revelation in
order to become a witch you must Sign
this book at her baptism but first she
has some questions
Faustus tries to quell her apprehensions
telling her that the devil isn't the
embodiment of evil rather the embodiment
of free will and that by signing the
book she won't go to hell because that's
only reserved for mortals witches are
exempt she brings up her boyfriend and
Faustus tells her those relationships
are discouraged mainly because he would
age much faster than her the only reason
her mother and father were allowed to
Wed was that the Dark Lord made an
exception she discusses what she saw
when she bit into the malum malice
stating that the future she saw was
horrible but was it the future in
Episode one we see the thirteen hanging
witches which apparently happened in
1692 regardless Faustus says the use of
a malum malice hasn't been recommended
for decades because of its unreliability
we also get a sweet view of his manicure
he makes an impassioned speech to get
her to take the baptism that should she
not like it she may leave the church at
any time but before he goes Ambrose
brings up the mysterious witch's mark he
found in episode 1 if it is what they
think it is it could mean a witch
hunters on the loose the boy himself was
adopted by two mortal parents who didn't
know he was a witch leaving him
defenseless furthering faustus's
argument that Sabrina should choose the
path of night so that she can learn to
protect herself
Faustus also tells Ambrose that it's
unlikely a witch hunter is out there but
he'll be sure to bring it up with the
council Hilda tell Sabrina that Faustus
used to be your father's mentor but her
father surpassed him in powers which
leads me to believe that there might be
some animosity here or something he
isn't quite telling her Sabrina asks
hilda if she had any doubts about her
baptism to which she tells a strange
story about walking through the forest
and watching it burn but little do they
know Zelda's creepily eavesdropping from
the ceiling and Salem is eavesdropping
on Zelda she
is there no privacy in this home harvey
surprises sabrina by showing up for
breakfast to ask Sabrina if she wants to
celebrate her birthday the day after her
baptism but we know if she goes through
with it she won't be able to even sadder
is how Harvey thinks they can spend
every Saturday together remember back in
episode one that Sabrina put a spell on
him so that he'd forget about their
conversation about her being a witch so
he still doesn't know she'll be gone
forever
back at the school the jocks rip up the
Wicca poster and Susie goes Rambo but
gets knocked out not only that she's the
one who ends up with the suspension
sabrina presses her asking who was
responsible and she goes to puppet
master miss Wardwell demanding that
these boys be held accountable
the last thing Sabrina wants before she
leaves is to leave her friends in
trouble
miss Wardwell says sometimes the only
way to fight fires with Hellfire and
Sabrina knows just the witches that can
help she summons Agatha prudence and
Dorcas and makes a deal if they help her
teach the jocks a lesson she'll agree to
stay at Baxter High and of course she's
crossing her fingers when she says it
they agree warning her because they're
her enemies she'll have to do most of
the work and angry and Zelda has some
great one-on-one time with Hilda
smashing her face with a hammer because
she's getting in the way of Sabrina
becoming a witch I have no mad
we then see her finishing the grave as
the parents of Connor the stabbed boy
arrived to look at their deceased son
Ambrose treats the parents to tea and
questions them about Connor
apparently he loved talking to his
lizard and Ambrose tells Zelda he
believes it could have been the boys
familiar the jocks drink beers outside
the gas station because you know that's
the cool thing to do when they're
interrupted by Sabrina and the girls who
are looking to party in the abandoned
mine because you know that's a normal
thing to do the mines are called The
Devil's doorway with one shaft leading
directly to hell the girls lead them to
the devil's lair where prudence exclaims
it's getting too hot probably because
they're close to him the devil and they
do what teenagers do in abandoned mine
shafts take off their clothes but the
boys are under a spell and tricked into
kissing each other just wait until
Baxter High hears about this if any of
those boys touch Susie or harm a girl
again those photos will be plastered all
over the school but prudence isn't done
with them going a step beyond what
Sabrina asked and playing devil in the
dark in which the lights go out and the
girl
spook the boys with her demonic faces
not only that the girls stole their
boyhoods and trapped them as Canaries
until they're released the boys will
remain impotent prudence is shocked to
hear that father Blackwood came and
visited Sabrina as if these girls needed
more reasons to be jealous of her
Sabrina tells them of her doubts she
doesn't want to give up her freedom of
power she wants her friends and to be a
witch Sabrina asks Harvey if he were
given the choice of superhero powers but
had to give up his friends would he do
it then he gets all romantic saying if
Sabrina was his girlfriend he'd say no
there's no flying in his life without
her
Hilda returns from the dead would Zelda
warns her each time she's killed it
takes longer for her to resurrect
apparently this isn't the first times el
does killed her younger sister older
sisters are given the right to kill
their younger siblings as many times as
they please
she tells her she won't have her swing
Sabrina and anything other than the path
of the night if not she'll be killed
again and look at this even more
eavesdropping what is with this it's
then my favorite time of year Halloween
the night of the dark baptism I even
loved the little witch on top of the
weathervane Hill to prepare Sabrina's
mother's wedding dress to wear for the
dark baptism and gives her words of
encouragement at breakfast Zelda tell
Sabrina that she and Hilda have errands
to do she's already called the school
saying that she won't be coming in today
which pisses Sabrina off because she
hasn't had a chance to say goodbye to
her friends at Baxter hi miss Wardwell
inquires to mrs. Meeks about Sabrina's
whereabouts before taking an unhealthy
amount of jellybeans
Sabrina asked Ambrose if she'll be able
to see her friends on the weekend and
the news isn't good witches are not to
have meaningful connections with mortals
it's highly discouraged and if she
doesn't follow the rules she'll be
weaned off the mortal world slowly
forgetting about those she cares of most
Zelda and Hilda go to pick up a Black
Goat likely to be used as a sacrifice in
the ceremony Harvey comes to pick up
Sabrina for one last night together
addressed as a minor
he invites Ambrose to the party but he's
under house arrest and will be banished
to the nether realm if he were to leave
then Sabrina reveals herself at her
mother's wedding dress and Henry almost
loses it at how beautiful she is
thank goodness his canary isn't in the
mine Ambrose reminds her to be on time
for the ceremony or it'll be held to pay
literally Roz welcomes them to the party
and they do the Monster Mash before a
mock cake is made to celebrate Sabrina's
birthday while slow-dancing harvey a
Sabrina what she wished for and she says
more of this Sabrina you dummy you're
not supposed to tell your wish to others
she then makes Harvey promise to
remember her no matter what but before
she can tell him why they're interrupted
by bras who excitedly explains the Blood
Moon is out reminding Sabrina she has to
get home she says one last passionate
goodbye to Harvey telling her she loves
him before leaving him bewildered as the
Blood Moon dark and Sabrina rushes
through the forest to make it to our
dark baptism under the Blood Moon her
dress transforms to black and blue
flames protect the entrance to where the
rituals to take place she's greeted by
Faustus who begins the ceremony
she's disrobed and kneels before him
asked if she would like to be free and
forsake the path of light to follow the
path of night to put the Dark Lord above
everyone in her life including her
friends and family she agrees and
Faustus leads her to sign the book also
miss Wardwell is eavesdropping
Faustus cuts her hand with a dagger and
pours her blood over the book and
Sabrina experiences flashes of the 13
dead witches the same thing she saw when
she ate the malum Alice her name must be
signed in her own blood and when it is
written she must obey any order received
by the Dark Lord or from any figure he
is placed in authority over her Sabrina
calls [ __ ] telling him that's not
what he said and we see the goat has
transformed into the creature she saw
merge from the old tree
Faustus told her she would have free
will she signed the book but now she's
being told she must obey any orders
given to her by the Dark Lord
Sabrina's doubts get the best of her and
she refuses to sign aunt Zelda says
don't you dare and Sabrina sees her
mother telling her to run and that's
exactly what she does but not before
she's entangled in the roots of the
forest she manages to break free asking
for Ambrose's help as she's chased by
dozens of witches and warlocks she's
given one last chance to sign but
Sabrina remains steadfast
is Sabrina Spellman and I will not sign
it away and Faustus does not like that
he closes his big ass book and marches
forward when Ambrose the necromancer
casts a spell in the house granting only
Spellman's the ability to cross into it
but we find out it's not a spell but
just enough to trick the witches into
backing off miss Wardwell tells the Dark
Lord him and we see the cross which was
once face-up in episode one now upside
down she pleads for mercy and must kiss
his hairy feet which I can't help but
draw a connection between the hairy feet
baby and episode one next morning at
breakfast Sabrina receives the cold
treatment from her aunt Zelda who seems
to be reading from a Russian newspaper
you can even see the flag of the Soviet
Union here
Zelda tells her she humiliated the
family in front of the entire coven
dishonouring the spellman name but
Sabrina tells her this wasn't what she
signed up for literally and that she saw
her parents in the woods
Ambrose calls this a spectral vision and
Sabrina tells them her parents didn't
want her to sign the book at Wicca
Wardwell arrives telling Sabrina that as
long as she's at Baxter High she wants
to work very closely with her when she's
interrupted by principal Hawthorne
Hawthorne is pissed about the club but
suddenly time stops
the Dark Lord takes control of him and
tells her he will stop at nothing until
she signs that but there's no way she
can defeat him because she is mortal and
on that ominous note the episode ends I
have no idea where this show is going
I'm writing these episodes as I go along
and you guys are probably way ahead but
I'm most curious about how she's gonna
retain her powers if she didn't sign the
book in episode 1 Ambrose tell Sabrina's
that witches who do not sign slowly lose
their powers is she willing to give that
up in order to be with her friends or
will there be like she said a third way
a way to do both with the amount of
people wanting her to sign something
tells me this isn't the last time we'll
be hearing from the Dark Lord and
finally the most important question
remains unanswered will the jocks get
their boners back stay tuned for more
breakdowns of Sabrina and make sure to
give it a like and subscribe with the
Belon I haven't watched all the episodes
yet but I'm gonna try to get out these
videos as fast as possible and as always
I love to hear your comments below and
if you post spoilers
they'll be hell to pay
so stay tuned